we've talked a lot about why carbon is
so awesome for life and a lot of it
comes out of the fact that carbon tends
to form four covalent bonds and that
comes out of the fact that carbon has
four valence electrons a neutral carbon
would have six electrons same as its
number of protons and then the six here
tells us the number of protons neutral
carbon would have six electrons two are
in its innermost shell which leave four
for its outer shell and those four in
the outer shell those are the electrons
that tend to do the reacting we call
them valence electrons and so for
example if you wanted to bond with four
hydrogens the carbon could contribute
one electron to each of the four bonds
and then each of the hydrogens could
contribute each of the hydrogens could
contribute an electron and then they
both feel like they have full outer
shells hydrogen's just trying to get to
two electrons in its outer shell is
trying to get to a stable configuration
like helium at least when it comes to
the electrons and carbon is trying to
get to a stable configuration like neon
and now carbon can pretend like it has
eight electrons it's sharing these eight
electrons and each of these hydrogens
can pretend like they have two electrons
but this makes carbon very well suited
for four covalent bonds you see this
methane right over here i have it
redrawn right over here but it's not
just bonding with hydrogens it can bond
with other carbons it can form these
hydrocarbon chains it can bond with
oxygen it can bond with other things and
so you might say all right i can buy
that carbon is good for life i
understand why life as we know it is
based on carbon but i see other elements
here that have four valence electrons
and in particular the one that's closest
to carbon on the periodic table is right
here silicon silicon has 14 electrons it
has 14 electrons but you have two in its
innermost shell i'll just draw them like
that they're buzzing around and it's
innermost shell right over there then
you have another eight in its second
shell so one two three four five six
seven eight and its second most shell so
i've used up 10 so far that leaves four
in its outermost shell one two
three four so silicon like carbon it has
more electrons it has eight more
electrons but its outermost shell has
four electrons and those are the ones
that tend to do the reacting so silicon
also has four valence electrons so let
me draw it like this
i'm using blue for silicon so let me put
blue
silicon
if i want to just draw its valence
electrons it also has four
it also has four valence electrons and
as you might have guessed silicon does
tend to form four covalent bonds and so
you might say okay well i could imagine
life that is based on silicon and if you
have done that you are not alone this is
a picture from 19 1967 the devil in the
dark episode of star trek where they
imagined a silicon-based life-form
called the horta
and science fiction
theorists and writers have always said
well you know silicon seems close to
carbon on the periodic table has four
valence electrons it tends to form four
covalent bonds
maybe maybe you could have silicon based
life but when you dig a little deeper
into the chemistry it it becomes less
and less likely i don't want to rule
anything out i'm sure the actual
universe will surprise us
and give us things that we we have we
can't even start to imagine but when you
start to think about silicon at least in
in terms of life as we know it it it the
chemistry isn't as favorable as carbon
for example carbon can readily bond to
itself carbon-carbon bonds are are
reasonably strong and strong enough to
form these hydrocarbon chains and they
can get much much much longer than this
while silicon silicon bonds are not that
strong so you're let you're not going to
find
the analog of hydrocarbons you're not
going to find long chains of
hydrosilicons i guess you could say so
that's
wonding for silicon
the other ding is you know this right
over here this is methane and silane
in theory
can be around but it does not readily
form silicon does not readily bond to
hydrogen this isn't that likely and then
the last one
you have carbon dioxide which is
obviously key for life and silicon oxide
is actually very very very common but
the problem with silicon oxide is it
doesn't typically act as a it's not
typically in a gassy state at least in
at at temperatures where we're used to
dealing with life most of the silicon
oxide on earth is in the form is in the
form of quartz like that or it's a major
component in things like glass or sand
it is in a solid form
and a big part of carbon diox what makes
carbon good not only does it not only
does it bond with tend to bond with four
things or form four bonds in this case
it's forming two double bonds in carbon
dioxide but those bonds are are are
strong enough to form chains like this
but they're but they're not so strong
that they can't that they can't
participate in a lot of chemistry and a
lot of chemical reactions while silicon
oxide this is very strong this is a very
strong bond here and it's hard for
silicon oxide to readily participate in
in chemical reactions the way that
carbon dioxide would also carbon dioxide
is is is can be can can be dissolved in
water while silicon oxide it does not it
is not soluble in many things so even
though silicon starts to you know it's
got the four valence electrons it can
form these four bonds um from there it's
it starts to become a little bit harder
to see how it could actually be the
basis of life but uh you know i
encourage you to keep thinking about how
how it could be maybe you know planets
with different temperatures or different
pressures or different conditions who
knows